hello folks how's everybody doing
I hope you're doing fine hope you're
ready getting ready for Christmas New
Year's okay today we have a busy
schedule so I'm gonna see if I can
answer some questions at the end but
don't count out in I'll try to do my
best here to win through this anyways I
am gonna start with a couple comments
made by one visitor okay yeah puts the
subject up today and in some kind of
perspective okay so here we go
individual serves accuses me right who
says anyone who says they can predict
the future the far future I think is
deluding themselves totally agree yeah I
don't know where he got that with that I
guess he's he's suggesting that I'm
predicting the future no again people
didn't get very mixed up with the issue
of extinction okay and I clarified it a
couple of times but this guy apparently
did not catch it and so I'll say it one
more time what we're explaining is the
mechanism of a better about background
okay I'm sorry I have a mass extinction
now those were explaining how the
animals in the past disappeared we're
explaining the mechanism and I'm saying
that they fell or disappeared when their
ecological pyramid overturned and what
I'm saying is that man cannot avoid that
same mechanism okay you got that right
okay so there's nothing about prediction
here well we're not saying that humans
are gonna die the whole I don't know the
first of may of 2030
that's not what we're saying here that's
religion that's astrology I don't do
astrology sorry
no predictions he says on how we may be
able to feed 10 billion people see and
he gives a reference right and I don't
know where he got that either again this
individuals not paying attention
we feed 10 billion people we can feed 11
we can feed 15 billion people maybe even
20 or more capitalism is a very
efficient system you know you gotta do
something for yourself and you go out
there you go out there and fill in a
niche in the economy and yeah you can
make a big buck and that allows you know
the economy to progress right so no he's
got this wrong I'm not saying that we
can't feed 10 billion or we can't feed
15 billion or 20 billion the Sonata
Malthusian type of theory this theory
has to do with something else that when
not if but when the economy collapses
the global economy collapses what do I
mean by that I mean money is no more you
will not accept money anymore
ok that's what I'm saying money will
collapse
we won't believe in money anymore we you
know God We Trust we don't trust them
anymore we become atheists in money when
that happens
no one has incentive to produce food not
for 10 billion for you for one person
no one will produce are distributed to
the cities ok that's the argument get
the argument straight okay right now
people are having trouble understanding
what I'm trying to say here but I took
issue with the last one the reference
below contradicts Bill's statement that
disease has has never wiped out a
species and he gives that reference
there ok ok so what do I have to say
about that well first of all this is
what this individual is referring to
there was this rat enormous rat on
Christmas Island near the near Australia
in the Indian Ocean and it was colonized
in 1888 by the United Kingdom about a
year or sometime earlier before that
some people went it there and they found
this rat they analyzed it by 1899 about
1011 years later a ship came over there
and
to mine phosphate and what they found is
that and what happened was some there
was some stowaway rats black rats you
know the ones that bring the diseases to
all parts of the world like the bubonic
plague and these rats brought us
sleeping sickness okay and so apparently
the sleeping sickness according to some
spread throughout the island among the
Democrats like this one here right and
it's known as mercury and what happened
was that within a few years apparently
they were all gone there was a stall
dirham
he collects some in the period of 1901
1902 where he when he visited the island
and those were the rats that we still
have today in museums there's a museum
over there on the island he collected
them he donated to the museum and these
rats were infected with that disease
okay so so that's our starting point
okay a starting point is there's just
rat apparently pretty to a paper that
I'm not sure in a second they died of
disease this disease brought by the
black rats and within a few years of raw
cotton okay that's that's the theory
okay
now this fella didn't do any research he
just took authority and just
regurgitated so see disease has killed
species in the past okay that's that's
his argument and so here's a paper
here's the original paper sorry wrong
one here it is here's the original paper
and by Wyatt and it L right company a
group of people who analyzed some of
these rats and the first thing that you
see is that they they're not as sure as
this other individual who put the
comment this absence of evidence cannot
be considered decisive given the few
samples available for analysis that's
the first thing we have to put in in the
proper context
but these researchers did they went to
the museum
in Christmas Island and they got a hold
of about I think 18 samples and they
analyzed in some of them most of them
had the disease they did some genetic
analysis they found that some of them
yeah most of them had the disease now
that's not surprising because this
fellow who donated them he didn't go out
there into the jungle to pick up live
rats what he did he picked up the dead
rats that died of the disease so you
know there was a selective collection
there you know we they collected dead
rats not lie breaths and eventually he
didn't donated them to the museum these
are the rest that this group in 2008
analyzes and says yeah the rats
apparently died of disease okay what's
the problem well we got a couple of
problems with that the first one is they
mention in passing hybridization that
there is a possibility that the black
rat which is that Radice there are
Rattus that they probably made it with
the materia and that's how the other
rats the McCurry's disappeared they
essentially became a new species okay
that's one one argument okay
personally I don't believe in that one
either just like these folks but I'm
just saying that there's other theories
out there the other issue is that you
know you have the island true and it was
alive all the way to 1985 many years
later many decades later and the
question why did the island shrew catch
the flu right and there's other animals
like there's a pipistrelle a small bat
also presumed to be extinct in this day
and age there was a flying frog there is
a flying fox appear to be the last
native mammal okay and so the question
is what happened to all the other
animals did they die because of this flu
as well and the fighting fox has other
problems has low rate of reproduction
and high infant mortality okay so we got
a problem because there are other
theories out there
I have a different theory for these
types of problems so you might find it
here yeah there's ears as a hint when I
consider a known species okay a species
which is about to die no matter what you
do whether it's endangered or not and
these are the clues Mother Nature gives
as far as I'm concerned okay
reproduction low fertility okay that's a
sign of an old species longevity lives a
long life that's a sign of an old
species sedentary doesn't colonize the
land anymore doesn't migrate that's
another sign disease resistant they to
the endemic disease in their region you
know if they don't move around they
eventually become immune to the great
extent to the diseases that plate them
throughout the centuries they're usually
big this rat was big
numerous this rat was numerous on that
island obviously it wasn't colonizing
any other place they were stuck on that
island genetic diversity low you don't
know about these rats nobody did a
genetic diversity analysis on them so I
have no that no date on that and it
resembles you know some of those
examples I give they're the passenger
pigeon Great Auk Thunderbird the more
bird which was some kind of ostrich has
Manian tiger Pyrenean ibex
so on so you know these are all species
they're about to die anyways okay and so
you know the fact that you have the
Tasmanian tiger and you have today the
Tasmanian Devil which is still alive
they were both were and are right
carnivorous marsupials that's a dinosaur
there's no such thing I mean these these
animals have outlived their their their
species lifespan almost you know they
had to die because they were at the end
of the line after millions of years of
evolving and who knows what so my take
on that is that animal
certain animals you know simply have
lived too long during old species we're
one of them we fit almost all those
criteria okay we have low reproduction
now okay in general and the average
right longevity we are among the mammals
that live the most longest lives who are
sedentary we no longer colonize anything
the whole planet is colonize we are
disease resistant we don't die of
disease a name or a contagious disease
except if there's a new one coming out
you know Ebola or something that just
pops out it comes into this to the world
the civilized world but you know the the
old diseases like smallpox it's are they
they've been eradicated we don't die of
those things anymore so we're disease
resistant to a great extent we die of
genetic diseases you know like diabetes
and cancer we don't die of contagious
diseases anymore not massively okay
sighs were big were among the biggest
there you see the little drying on the
bottom you know the famous you know
evolution they were growing okay we're
we're big for for our speed for monkeys
okay and we have no genetic diversity so
we fit all those criteria by the way we
are an old species and people said
you're crazy
what do you be we're adults PC we were
robbed maybe worth two hundred thousand
years that's what the official version
is mother nature does not according to
me right does not judge how old the
species is by how many times the earth
went around the Sun no the way she
judges is is by all those criteria
whether you're big whether you lost your
genetic diversity whether you're
numerous
whether you are sedentary and conquered
all endemic diseases etc etc etc okay so
we are an old specie we are about to die
no matter what
and I'm saying we're not dying of any of
that we're gonna die for a different
reason all together which is you know
the thing we cannot overcome which is
the same thing the animals in the past
could not overcome which is the
ecological the pyramid overturned the
overturning of the ecological pyramid
but getting back to this article here
was an article that came four years
later and again it shows you why you
have to be careful with what you read
out there you got to be skeptical of
everything you read why it is the first
group that published a report in 2008
here's an answer to that they say that
what Wyatt proprietor a circumstantial
evidence okay and there's no direct
evidence okay and again when you study
samples a hundred years old out of a
museum a very small sample you can't
draw global conclusions from that you
can have a theory and say they died of
disease that's okay but when you try to
impose that theory on other people
you're not doing science you're doing
religion okay you're doing politics but
I like that let that last statement that
this law said says attributing
prehistoric extinctions to infectious
disease has become almost a cottage
industry in the last two decades again
you got to be extremely careful with
what you read because theories theorists
like to impose their theory upon you
it's it's it's a normal human
you know behavior so nothing wrong with
that just you should be able to separate
science from religion from politics and
it's interesting that they in that paper
they've mentioned low genetic diversity
of the Tasmanian devil I mean for all we
know the McCleary died of low genetic
diversity you know maybe they were under
way out anyways again they were numerous
they were big maybe they had no legend
egg diversity you know there could be
other reasons why they died or other
factors that took them to their
extinction and and they weren't the only
animals that died by the way and not all
of them died of the disease and then
there was a another paper earlier in
1996 any people vote for hybridization
so again what this does is show you that
other people don't agree with disease
that the disease killed the rats there
are different opinions out there and we
don't care about the opinions we care
about the mechanism this guy says
hybridization gets other guys says
disease so farmer talking science that's
okay it's when you say mine is the truth
you should believe my theory that's when
we have a problem and again this fellow
I don't know well he's he likes
Authority a person he first paper he
read so yeah I know who hears disease
you know no we have no evidence that any
species ever on planet earth died of
disease okay
and if it try to prove that for the last
20-30 years and they have been able at
least to convinced
I mean proof is is not part of science
but they were able to convince their
colleagues people don't buy into this
disease extinction theory okay they say
okay that's your opinion that's fine but
we don't buy into it okay so what do I
really want to talk about today well
I've got the freewheel Ruiz and
anarcho-capitalist who believe we should
take government off our backs we have
too much government government only
interferes with with you know regular
trade and so we got to get rid of them
and so these people never buy into my
extinction theory because it's based on
economics and ball all these people are
experts in economics okay they they
they're experts you can't put anything
through them because they they know it
all by heart now I criticize them
because they don't know anything about
extinctions and what I'm talking about
is is extinction and they say well
you're talking about animals yeah
because that's all that become extinct
together with plants by the way in the
past you know we humans we haven't
become extinct so far you know and so
they said what you're talking about
animals but we're not animals and you
say
you're putting words in our mouths no
I'm not you know Pete I say look you got
a study you got to put a comment here
which nobody has so far after the third
episode here an extinction no one has
put a comment talking about how the M
was in the past died everybody just
wants to talk about man everybody's an
expert on man no one's an expert on
extinction and so when I say look you
got to study extinction first the
extinction of the animals so that you
can project whatever killed them to man
and find out if man can avoid that same
process whatever happened to them can we
avoid it with all their intelligence all
our technology although our smartness
and foresight and whatever can we avoid
the same mechanism that claimed the
lives of these species in the past and
they say well it's irrelevant why is it
a row so relevant because we're not
animals
that's that's essentially their argument
okay and so a party I gotta establish
that we are animals you say bill that's
overkill no it's not because we can't
use the word animal in two different
ways in science we can't use the word
animal in biology so we know what an
animal is biologically but then you know
move on and say well but we're not gonna
use that definition for economics or for
extinction that's where we have a
problem right now we're having a big
problem with the word animal people
don't know what an animal is and they
don't know where the humans are animals
are not so I'm going to establish that
here it's a you know laying the
foundation for extinction I didn't think
I needed to do this but yeah I do need
to establish that humans are animals
that belong to the animal kingdom
maybe the narco cops and the free
willies maybe they believe they they're
rocks or plants I don't know so I'm
gonna establish it sorry I need to do
this because these people don't believe
it so here's yes there are you - NC okay
they say we're not animals so we have to
look at the definition of animal what is
an animal okay I mean if we're gonna
talk about extinction of animals we
better know what an animal
and here we find the definition gay says
animals are multicellular eukaryotic
organisms you garota
eukaryotes are organisms whose cells
have nucleus enclosed within membranes
okay now if you fit that description
you're an animal now if you have a
different definition you know you should
start there you should start with your
definition okay and so where do humans
fit in with this definition I mean
within the world of animals if we're
animals right and this is the
classification we have today we have we
belong to the kingdom of Animalia they
were animals we are mammals we are
hominids and we are homonyms okay what
are these categories okay real quick
like so we go through them you're going
to challenge them later okay
what are these categories well mammals
says that we are breast feeders
essentially that's what it is mammary
glands that's what we have women do I
don't we have fern hair now I don't know
maybe those narco calves think they have
what is it scales or feathers I don't
know go out of focus here yeah I don't
know I don't know if they think they're
different
no they I'm sure they have furn hair and
we are hominins and there you have a
whole list of them that died before us
one nine the bitch'll that I found out
out there on the internet says why are
we the only human species still alive
today whereas many of our early human
ancestors referring to the hominids
right
what extinct and so this is the notion
people have what we did not go extinct
because we're special
we're not even animals or we're a
special type of animal that can avoid
extinction we're not like the other
animal we're not like them okay that's
what that's their argument essentially
they never specified exactly how I'm
gonna get into that in a second but but
they considered animals different than
us
and so maybe that's the wrong conclusion
maybe the conclusion is something else
maybe the last of a dynasty of rulers of
the planet like in our case or the three
your exes or Dimetrodon and the Permian
and so on
maybe those died in a mass extinction
and not like all these other Falls died
in a background extinction okay so there
are different interpretations why we are
the only species of hominins left alive
and yeah we also with chimps and
gorillas affirm the the groups known as
hominids okay so we are among the last
of the hominids there's a few of those
still left but we are the last of the
hominin we have no one to make with no
one to enrich our genetic diversity
which is almost gone today okay so
that's in a nutshell the story there so
are we different than the animals well
people will say we are different because
we have a brain oh so we have a brain
well you know animals have brains I mean
mammals as far as I know all of them
have brains
okay so maybe we have a more
sophisticated brain you know maybe we
are able to think in abstract mode well
personally I don't think that's an
advantage I mean you have people who
believe in God others believe in spirits
others believe that the Stars influence
our thoughts or our behavior or whatever
others others believe in space-time and
black holes so I'm not sure that
thinking in the abstract is a an
advantage of any kind I'm sure a bear is
more intelligent than some of these
people okay so that's one issue but then
they raised the issue of consciousness
consciousness okay so what are you being
consciousness what is consciousness and
when you look it up you know you find
out that there is no definition of the
word consciousness okay what you have
here is a definition from the Wikipedia
and
below that you'll see the one that we
had from miss and mrs. n ran which I've
been dealing with in the past couple
weeks and they all pretty much match
again they have no idea what the word
consciousness means but they talk a lot
about it and it says sentience or
awareness of internal or external
existence which is more or less what in
ran said and but I like the comment that
comes after says despite centuries of
analysis definitions explanations and
debates by philosophers and scientists
consciousness remains puzzling and
controversial being at once the most
familiar and most mysterious aspect of
our lives perhaps the only widely agreed
notion about the topic is the intuition
that it exists so here yeah people talk
about a concept that exists
consciousness units out there's you know
when I die my consciousness remains the
spirit bill behind so they have no idea
what the word consciousness or conscious
means and I only ask the following
there's a wildebeest that's being eaten
by four or five lionesses right they
just hunted him down
is that wildebeest aware of pain see
conscious of pain is that wildebeest
aware of the existence of the lioness is
munching on him right that very moment
how is that different than when you have
pain in on your soror sore thumb you're
aware of pain aren't you and so is the
wildebeest so how consciousness makes us
different than animals I have no idea
because I have no definition of
consciousness that we can use
consistently in science so I'm gonna
relegate the word consciousness to
religion anyone using out is talking
religion okay it's as simple as that
we have no definition to word
consciousness and again name ran was one
of the ones who spent a lot of time on
that wound and wrote a lot about it she
had no idea what it was okay but I like
mr. Charlie Darwin's notion better okay
what what the Charlie say well you said
there is no far
metal difference between man into higher
mammals in their mental faculties all
the differences are of degree not of
kind okay someone on the unit put a
comment or saying these differences
these gradual changes make us
extraordinary meaning makes us a special
kind of animal we're kind of different
than the animals you know that's like
saying that because the cheetah is the
fastest you know it runs any other
animal the cheetah is not an animal or
the whale king of bigness of size not an
animal because he's so big and here we
are we are the king of brains or the
king of intelligence or consciousness
does that make us a non animal does that
make us not an animal does that take us
away from the Wild Kingdom and so this
is the issue the issue is whether any of
those things are relevant and here I
went out there made a list you can
object to the list or maybe improve on
it put some more things in there take
some out okay and here's a list of
things that I picked up that make us
different than the rest of the animal
kingdom we engage in trade because we
store goods and have something to trade
I had a host Downes okay we have gone
into space we can change our environment
we produce our own food we invent
technology we appreciate art we are
rational animals well I'll take
exception with some people out there
pursuing now this for its own sake we
study other animals and write books
about them physically we are another
primate but our bigger brains are
unusual okay so we have big brains you
know
so what brain size we seem to owe more
complex reasoning abilities to it humans
have out altruism more teamwork co-op
cooperation right than chimps who need
bigger bribes nudging okay you need to
nudge or bribe or chimp to a higher
degree than a human Bessy a kid a baby
toddler to get to do some things until
he learns you know how the real world
works
we are certainly unique in the level of
of abstractness with which we can reason
about others mental states are parallel
language skills we link our scenario
building minds into larger networks of
knowledge we can share information at
the touch of a button and we also peer
further back in time and further into
the future than any other animal ok so I
think that covers at least a lot of what
people in general think that separates
us from the rest of the animal kingdom
the first question is does that make us
not an animal but then there's uh
there's more pertinent issue that deals
with what we're dealing here with
extinction and here are the five million
dollar questions okay and these are the
ones that you should answer okay if
you're going to if I get this thing in
there if you're going to challenge the
theory can't read save you from death
can technology compel City women
civilize women to have ten babies like
in the days of the farms and days of
Agriculture women used to have 810
babies no longer can consciousness help
you avoid growing old can going into
space prevent you from pooping or
urinating and can the ability to change
our bond and stop you from sleeping or
eating or what are called the vitals
what thus the fact that we have
differences such as the ones mentioned a
minute ago have to do with death or with
extinction but does the fact that we
have assuming we concede you know we
have a higher consciousness a higher
intelligence intelligence level we can
see the future what does that have to do
with it with your death does the fact
that you can see the future better than
then a bear wolf does that help you live
longer or stay alive longer does it can
you
however because of that can you just
keep thinking in advance and saying ah
that therefore I can avoid death so what
does our differences or do our
differences between the animal kingdom
rest of the animal kingdom have to do
with death and with extinction that's
what you got a tie see if you're gonna
say well we're not animals we're not
like the animals in the past like the
dinosaurs or or the Vivien's or the
arcus ours right okay so we're not like
that I guess we didn't have scales we
didn't have feathers right we didn't
have fur we we have hair insulin right
so so we're different yeah in what way
does those the fact that we have
differences such as the ones mentioned
before make us live longer or make you
as an individual live longer okay these
are the questions we get we gotta tie it
in because otherwise you're just stating
and you're not making a point what's
your point
yeah we're different so so as a cheetah
cheetah is different and runs faster so
it's the whale it's big bigger than
anything else is that why it's not an
animal is that why it's gonna live
forever or not live forever what's it
got to do what does bigness or speed
have to do with death or with extinction
RV is is the cheetah gonna outrun
extinction okay so this takes us to the
possible scenarios that I mentioned the
other day and these are these are rather
than Wikipedia it's people who give
reasons for why man is might become
extinct yeah you have two choices you
either say that man does become extinct
or he does that he'll look forever some
people believe that man would look
forever they're not off the hook they
have to tell us how how man is going to
avoid whatever killed the animals in the
past so you got no choice but to go back
and say well this how this animal died
and this is how we're gonna avoid what
killed him that's what you got to do and
for those who believe that humans are
gonna become extinct someday somehow
these are the proposed
okay and then you know the first few
come from or match the ones we find in
the Bible you know the four horses of
the Apocalypse and I call it horse is
not horseman because another version is
that there was only one horseman with
different horses okay so that's another
version just in case you're wondering
and yeah we have pestilence okay and
there we have infighting and we have
conquest okay so you can see just by
looking at the diseases and the nuclear
warfare among humans those match more or
less what the Bible says that can speak
is one that's missing is famine you know
the black horse he's not in there and we
don't we don't consider famine a
possibility today you won't find it in
any Theory okay nobody will talk about
famine humans dying of you know of the
fact that they have nothing to eat okay
nobody mentions that okay we have added
some we have added catastrophes all
kinds as you can see there's there's
several votes and and then we added
climate change which is very popular
today everybody talks about global
warming all that nonsense and it's
nonsense not because I don't believe in
global warming or climate change
it's nonsense because it has nothing to
do with extinction that's why it's
nonsense it's when people bring that and
say oh we're on a verge of becoming
extinct because of global warming or
climate change that's when I reject that
completely
yes that's my personal attitude towards
climate change habitat threats never
going to happen
overpopulation exceeding the environment
that's a Malthusian argument and I don't
I personally don't buy into it I think
capitalism can produce as many goods as
you want again we can sustain 10-15
billion people it's just a matter of
price okay last one I totally disagree
population declined through a preference
for fewer children the problem is it's
not a question of preference this is not
a freewill issue okay these people think
that women have a choice the free
builders you know free Willys they say
oh we have free will
women have free will they can choose to
have a baby
no they don't they don't women do not
woman yeah women do that okay and a
routine here's proof okay you want proof
in truth and evidence okay let's let's
give you proof and truth in evidence
here's the birth rate I'm sorry the
growth rate for Humanity okay by the mid
century or thereabouts we're gonna have
zero population growth why are we gonna
have zero population growth because even
though death rates will be will increase
over time because we have an older
population birth rates are declining
drastically since 1963 that was the last
year where we had the highest level 2.2
I think it was two point there about 2.3
and and today we're at somewhere around
up one and that's going down too
I'm sorry I'm talking about the growth
rates and you know by the time we get to
2050 we're gonna have a growth rate of
zero that means one person dies one
person is born okay and I'm not sure
about the birth and I think it's
probably gonna occur much sooner than
that why is that the case well because
we have a transition from the country to
the city people moving from the country
to the cities in the country you can
have ten babies in the cities in an
apartment you can't have ten babies
period we're done that's the reason so
it's not that the Africans spit out
children like you know rabbits and the
Palestinians also because they have a
high rate now once they get into cities
everybody every human stops having
children
the issue is movement from the country
to the cities the agricultural
corporations are buying out the lands
pushing out the individual farmers who
can't compete against the big guys and
they come to the city with their
families and that transition is going on
in all countries in the world especially
in that we don't see this in the
advanced countries as much but in the
underdeveloped nations that's that's a
revolution that's happening as we
you know the big corporations are buying
out the lens and the small farmers can't
pay the rent or they can't pay the loan
or the mortgage or whatever right and so
they're being kicked out more or less
like the enclosure movement of the
sixteenth century if you look that up
you know who has a Thomas Moore said
sheep are eating men because everybody
was dedicating the but used to be public
land up to that point they were
enclosing it with fences and pretty
cheap in there which was a more
lucrative business than you know
planting potatoes and it's the same
thing more or less we have an enclosure
movement now where the big corporations
are taking over the land there they have
these economies of scale in which they
produce food and distribute to the
cities and lots of governments are
behind all that because you know they're
all friends you know the rich people
with the government and so they say look
why don't you pass a law in this
direction in that direction and so you
know people are being kicked out of
their lands anyways we have a transition
from the country to the city when people
come to the city they no longer have
children you can't have children in a
dense environment where you have no
unemployment and no money no disposable
income and not a not a good environment
to grow children you know and a lot of
women choose
you have a free lilius they choose not
to have babies on an average they don't
have so so yeah no we're having babies
is thinking of the past it's animal
behavior and we're not animals okay so
so and here's the population curve that
I proposed for humans if we really for
any species this is the puppy yeah you
heard of the best curve yes curve is
nonsense they never finished that last
part of the s so I'll finish it for them
here it is I can get this thing up there
this is the population curve for any
species it starts out a long time ago
thousands of years ago
first exceed deaths
and there's lots of deaths but there's
breasts a little over the deaths okay
you have a higher rate of birth than you
have of this it's a very slow progress
yeah you got a lot of bottlenecks a lot
of founders defects in between and by
the time they become an old species we
get the births approximate equal best
births begin to equal thus and the final
collapse is when births fewer the best
the population pyramid overturns and the
species becomes extinct and that's more
or less where you see that in red you
are here that's more or less where we
are on the curve and you can see how
much time we probably have just by
looking at the curve as if if economics
would occur before that okay I I suspect
that the economy is gonna collapse much
earlier than our population pyramid
happens to overturn completely okay okay
so where does that take us these are
what I call the vitals again let's start
with those and what I'm saying that
these are the things you need to stay
alive this is as in as an individual
okay you need to breathe you need to
drink you need to eat they say breathing
a couple of minutes and you're dead if
you don't breathe right if you don't
drink I think it's five days and eating
I guess you can go maybe a month I don't
know about two months certainly not a
year okay so those are vitals you need
those otherwise you die you become
extinct and all the cells in your body
after all you know yeah you know I'm
bill but I'm made of a bunch of cells
which are made of a bunch of molecules
which are made of a bunch of atoms now
the atoms and the molecules are not
alive so we don't have to worry about
them but the cells yeah they are alive
that's the unit that that's the first
unit that became alive on earth and you
know they they need to breathe drink and
eat
they don't they die too so you can take
that collection of cells and say that we
have a mass extinction when I die all
the cells die like the colonies that
comprise me they die yeah so we have a
mass extinction and these are the vitals
you do is you need to pump right you
need to sleep I don't know maybe I
missed a couple possible but these are
things that kill you now we're talking
about death okay we're now talking about
stuff that has nothing to do with death
these are things that have to do with
death so at least let's get some of the
basics right okay and and here you have
some of the maybes okay these you can
talk a lot about you know gravity do we
need gravity do we need magnetism of the
earth do you need to have someone love
you care for you or whatever do you need
company I mean maybe you can get a dog
or whatever you know antibodies to
protect you from diseases do we need
genetic diversity and this is always on
the individual basis I'm talking about
individuals here right do you need earth
under your feet well if you're in space
you can still live so you don't need
really the earth under your feet so all
of these are maybes you know you can
argue about them a long time the ones on
the left you absolutely need the ones on
the right well you know you can go into
a lot of arguments and a lot of
situations
okay how about reproducing do we need to
reproduce well I would say the
individual doesn't need to reproduce
some individuals never reproduce in
their entire lives
understand they live out their lives who
you know old age okay so we don't need
to reproduce how about trade and
commerce about this guy okay do we need
to trade well I mean hunter-gatherers
didn't need to trade and neither did
subsistence farmers so now we don't need
trade on an individual basis you know
you can say today we we might need it
but see what you're talking about if
you're gonna include reproduction and
trade you're talking about the global
population now disappearing now you're
referring to you know if we don't
reproduce our race our species then for
sure we're going to go extinct and if we
don't trade today if somehow God weight
comes over here and waves this magic
wand and somehow eliminate strayed from
our minds so we no longer want to trade
for whatever reason well I can bet you
we're gonna die because the only thing
that keeps us going today is trade okay
so without trade we're dead
okay now trade is is a little worrisome
because he trade does not really produce
any any good any any wealth anything new
okay trade means that something existing
is is exchanged but it doesn't produce
anything new okay
anyway this here's the extinction
flowchart which I propose for those who
want to challenge the theory okay
first you need to tell me whether we are
animals or not in other you got to
define but what the word animal means
you can't keep saying well I'm not going
to worry about the animals in the past
because we're not animals which is
essentially your argument or we're not
right to them now that is us and us is
them we're all the same we're animals we
have all the vitals we have blood
running through our veins you know we
breathe we we sleep we eat so you can't
you can't say we're we're not animals
and so we are part of that animal
kingdom if we're not if you think we're
not then you got to specify you know
what what an animal is and what a human
is it with respect why we're not animals
okay and what we are in the alternative
and if you say well these are our
differences you got to show that our
differences are related to extinction
and to death you got to show me that if
you say trade you got to show me why
trade is gonna make you live longer or
you absolutely need trade or you're
gonna die tomorrow morning
like the bagels okay then you gotta
answer the question will man new forever
and some people say yes some people say
no okay so those who say yes they can't
avoid the issue anyways they have to
tell me why the how we're going to avoid
with two of the animals in the past for
this you need to tell me how the animals
in the past disappeared and of course
people don't like to do that because
they want to talk economics they want to
say how great how smart we are but they
don't want to tell you how animals
disappeared to the past I do have a
mechanism telling you it was food food
disappeared then the animals disappeared
and the food is going to disappear on
humans and we're going to disappear for
the same reason so I do have a mechanism
we can't avoid running out of food we
run out of food because our economy
collapses and the only reason we produce
food is because of trade because of our
economy and when you look at it money as
an abstraction that's becoming more
abstract day by day you know it used to
be we used to have food for we used to
trade food like for you know carpentry
and blacksmithing you know maybe you
bought a a sword for so many pounds of
wheat or whatever right and then we went
into gold whenever we win at the paper
money and today we've gotten rid of all
that we we're numbers in a bank account
it's all you know checking accounts and
savings account and Bitcoin and whatever
it's all about electronic money that's
how abstract our money has become and
some people don't see a problem with
that you know our very lives depend on
this abstraction so you know I have a
reason for saying that man cannot avoid
starving because all we need is for that
system to collapse and no one produces
food no one delivers food and we all die
so I do have a mechanism the person who
says we're going to avoid that has to
have I mean you don't have to accept
that theory of course not I'm not saying
that you have to accept the theory I'm
just asking you to understand it
and and then you have to tell me if you
say that man's gotta live forever how
he's gonna avoid what all the other
animals could not because we are animals
and for those who say no bans I gotta
live forever
well you better have a foolproof
mechanism you can't say well asteroids
gonna hit the earth what if it does it
does that mean we look forever and we're
gonna throw the nukes at each other what
if we don't we look forever so this is
the issue the issue you have to have a
food pool is something we can't avoid no
matter what and the mechanism I'm
proposing I'm saying you can't avoid no
matter what our economy will collapse we
cannot grow forever in great measure
because we're not producing consumers
we're not producing children and so at
some point the global economy will
collapse party because we have nothing
more to invent there's nothing else that
we need to make our lives more
comfortable so that's not like we're
gonna invent more gadgets in the future
that will be sold and create new
industries no such monster
the industries we have right now are
merging and becoming fewer or viewer
that they have all these economies of
scale in their attempt to cut down costs
and what that does is create more
unemployment and that unemployment is
masked or covered or taken care of by
the people who do work you know the
government takes money from them and
pastes welfare pays the retirement
that's also unemployment and any
unemployed people who are without a job
it does and then there you have all
those people who seek jobs out there you
know like selling drugs or whatever
because they have no jobs or women who
you know you you look at YouTube you
find all these women just showing their
bodies and making money have millions of
hits and they receive money I mean the
prostitute used to have to sleep with a
guy today the women don't have to sleep
with a guy anymore they just show their
bodies and he collect so those are the
jobs we have today you know we have
great jobs today people don't see a
problem with that you know the
officially the free willies and the
the problem with that they think it's
normal they don't see any danger in that
okay anyways let's see if I can finish
up here let's go with this these are my
proposals okay and first I'm saying that
you know we need to explain extinction
101 then you have to tell me if humans
will ever die if not you have to tell me
why not why they can avoid you know what
the animals could not avoid and then
finally you have to tell me if you think
that man is gonna be coming sing extinct
you have to tell the crowd you know you
have to give them a foolproof mechanism
okay that's in a nutshell now here are
my factors okay that I consider when I
look at the collapse of the global
economy okay and sure the free willies
are all going to disagree with me on 90%
of these I'm just telling you what I
factor in when I talk about the
extinction of man because of the
collapse of the economy okay and here
are the things that I look at so I'm
gonna just run through them I'm not
gonna explain them in any detail right
now we have population populations the
first topic that I look at population
bottlenecks and foundering effects they
reduce our genetic diversity which they
have over the years okay that leads to
genetic disorders
or the period of colonization is over we
don't do anymore we don't conquer any
territory that's over with okay we
conquered the entire earth essentially
we're not gonna find any new cities
there's this transition from the country
to the city going on right now where the
cities are becoming mega cities and the
country is becoming depleted taking over
by the agricultural corporations which
feed the cities the cities are becoming
overcrowded that creates mental
disorders of all kinds the family type
changes okay women have fewer babies and
population pure pyramid over terms okay
that's that's my perspective there and I
just want to show how the family type
has changed over the years
with respect to the mode of production
most of this is Marxist theory day and
hunter-gatherers they had group sex
agricultural phase where we had slaves
and also later on serfs that was a
patriarchy type of arrangement you have
one wide many slaves the guy probably
slept with half of them you know then we
went to the nuclear family mom and pop
the children and today we have the lone
bachelor the divorcee The Bachelor the
single guy right and sex is really more
recreational it's not for reproduction
okay so that's in a nutshell what has
happened over the years as far as I'm
concerned those are things I looked at
when I look at population how about
factor number two okay and again you
don't have to agree with any of these
I'm just saying what I look at okay and
that there are going to cause the
economic collapse factor number two
unemployment we have the number of
consumers drop because we're not
producing consumers we're not there is a
new generation of consumers demand
declines corporations don't sell they
can't create new products because there
are no new products that we need like in
the past we needed telephone we needed
airplanes we needed cars we don't need
any of that anymore we got them we can't
reinvent the wheel so there's massive
layoffs services is an abstract economy
it's unreal there's no such thing as
services it's a promise
I call it mass unemployment wealth is
only material things you know imagine
your god or you're a Martian you come to
earth and you look at the Earth from
above or you see a big city when all
these skyscrapers and then you see a
little village with all these you know
huts and you look at these two do you
think you can tell which one has more
wealth just by looking at those two
pictures and the answer is yes of course
because those are material things did
you see any services in there
no services are promised or abstract
things you there is no such thing as
service even when you cut somebody's
hair or cut his lawn you know move the
lawn
you're not producing anything really
you're not producing anything so service
is a BS economy and 85% of the economy
of like the United States of Europe
Japan that services and all the other
countries are imitating that you know
the trading Commerce do not produce
wealth and we have transition from
manufacturing to services to
unemployment that's the mode of
production now we have more and more
unemployment which which implies also
you know welfare retirement etc yeah and
then you have underdeveloped nations
copy the service model of the advanced
nations everybody wants to be you know
this leisure society where where you
have you know all services tourism all
beautiful things and nobody produces any
wealth there's no increase in wealth in
material things that's what wealth is
right and let's see we go from there to
another aspect and that's what I these
are things I look at here are the
entitlements okay and you know the in
order to keep the peace governments have
to institute this it's like they have no
other choice and you know the free will
you say in the narco cap say well we
should stop helping all these people you
know let them get under feet all by
themselves well but no government on
earth does that so that has to make you
stop and think whether we can do without
government and whether government can do
such a thing I mean the politicians are
self-interested and they want to be
reelected and aside from that they don't
want a revolution they don't want a
civil war so they have to do these
things they have to give money to the
poor to keep them bad to keep them quiet
the reason we have no no problems here
in Europe is that you know everybody
gets his money no matter what if you go
to the other other countries like in
Africa and South America
and some of some in Asia they have
revolutions and civil wars and all these
kinds of problems steaming etc yeah
because they don't get any money from
the government the guy is unemployed
he's got nothing to look with he's he's
a little unhappy okay so yeah I don't
know the Free Willy is there they they
fix every problem very easy but I can't
I personally don't agree with that okay
anyways unemployment rises welfare rises
population ages and that means that we
have more retirees okay
real cost increases government prints
more money to cover the holes government
borrows and incur stepped all
governments are indebted today okay and
interest becomes an ever-growing of
percentage of GDP so these are in
general things that I look at okay you
don't have to agree with them I'm asking
you to agree I'm saying this is what I
look at okay and next one is money
okay another aspect I look at okay here
it is we have devaluation the currency
almost every country has that to a large
extent as they match their currency
against others in order to be able to
export and import etc our real wages
follow disposable income Falls demand
falls further money gradually loses its
value and governments default on
international loans in fact Argentina
right now my country you know has
serious problems they not only are
devaluating the coin but they're
wondering either go pay the
International Monetary Fund so you know
you gotta be careful with them find out
how they're gonna do it and in one
suggestion I always do because people
say buddy
what do you mean money is good at this
if you what do you mean we're not gonna
believe in money what do you mean what
do you mean we're going to become
atheists and money and here's the
scenario you know you he was this guy
walking into your shop in Michigan right
and he says Joe how much does that cost
that's ten dollars ok I'll buy it but
I'll pay you with argentine pesos
and Joseph are you crazy I don't accept
Arjun type these will be this money it's
legal tender it's backed by the
Argentine government well all I can tell
you don't accept argentine pesos okay
that's a Nigerian scam okay
Nigerians created that scan because
Argentina beats them with soccer every
time and so they use Argentine money to
pay for things don't accept Argentine
money okay so for all those people who
think that money is money as money no
money is not money you don't accept
Argentine money please don't
okay it's fake money anyways okay and
then the last aspect I look at is this
one and which is unrest okay and what
happens is yeah because countries not
everybody can be rich not everybody can
have a decent life out there and
governments will continue paying
whatever they can to keep people at
peace but you're gonna have massive
strikes you're gonna have revolutions or
you're gonna have crime and you're gonna
have civil war so I don't think you can
avoid any of these things and again I'm
not asking you to agree with all my
things that I look at you know when I
look at the collapse of the economy I'm
just saying that all these things are
negative all these things drive us to
the destruction of our economy our
global economy or artificial economy as
I call this trade thing that we invented
and trade will fall trade as far as I'm
concerned will disappear it can't
continue forever and here's the big
picture I showed it last I'm going to
show it one more time and that's this
one that we had we were hunter-gatherers
turning over to maybe 200,000 years for
the last 10,000 years we went into
farming and these are just ballpark
numbers about 200 to 300 years ago we
went to manufacturing industry and some
parts of the world about 50 years ago we
rented the services and that's already
an unemployment
the society as far as I'm concerned an
unemployment mode of production we're
not producing anything real real okay
and and we also have higher unemployment
or unemployment's going to be growing as
we become more and more efficient okay
so I don't think we can avoid that and
so what's the end result of all that
well here's if you look at that same
history here it is in pictures we
started out as hunter-gatherers killing
maybe some animal there in the middle of
nowhere we went into agriculture then we
went to manufacturing from there to
services from there we go to
unemployment from there we return to
hunter-gathering but this time we go
into hunter-gathering in the asphalt
jungle we start killing each other we do
and do cannibalism that's how humans
will end as far as the building is
concerned yeah okay so I'm sure I upset
at least half of the free Willie's up
there but that's how I think and I think
that we're gonna die exactly like the
dinosaurs like the Ark asuras like the
synapses like the amphibians we're gonna
die exactly like them because we can't
avoid what they avoid what they can
avoid which is the overturning of the
ecological pyramid the many chasing the
few we're going to run out of food
because no one's going to plat food
today we we like someone said and I've
included there in the in the list we are
an animal that can plant food and create
our own food we do that and but we did
this for money for economic gain for
personal reasons when that personal
reason disappears when money disappears
when money is no more when you would no
longer accept argentine pesos well at
that point you don't have an incentive
to produce something for someone else or
deliver it to the to the cities and
people cannot imagine that officially
the free Willy's and the narco caps they
said well that's impossible it cannot
even imagine such a world because they
were born in Disneyland and so they
think Mickey Mouse and Donald Duck are
for real anyways that's my take I'm
going to continue on
Wednesday with this let's see if I can
answer some question but I doubt it
because I'm out of time well let's see
if there's anything worth it it's all
about making movie the great scientists
were okay there's a party okay
eating is a personal reason okay I'll
have to look at some of these Lou I have
to look at some of these issues next
time I don't think we have time today
but all I'm saying if if you want to
challenge the theory the theory again is
the overturning of the ecological
pyramid okay that's the theory what and
what does that mean it means that all
the animals in the past that died in a
mass extinction not a background
extinction a mass extinction died
because their ecological pyramid
overturn we had the many chasing a few
we have the more carnivores chasing
fewer herbivores which chased fewer
plants of the type that they ate now
some people who asked the question well
hold it Billy
why did the dinosaurs you know and then
the herbivores died they could have
eaten something else and the answer is
no they can't eat something else because
there is nothing else big to feed a
t-rex I mean when the Triceratops
disappear or the hadrosaurs or the until
SARS
you know when when these other animals
that tries to that t-rex ate disappeared
he can't go into they're eating potato
chips you know mammals little mice
that's like you trying to say well I
don't eat meat anymore I don't need to
load us anymore because there's nothing
there
so I'm going to eat ants okay so you ask
how easy is it to eat ants well first of
all you have hands to you know to eat
ants but see the dinosaurs could not do
that they didn't have the versatility in
their in their movements to go in there
and look for little mice mammals you
know to eat those and and not fill their
stomachs anyways so now you can't switch
overnight partly because you know you've
been used to eating the same type of
animals for millions of years you get
out suddenly switch your your your diet
even as a carnival
assuming there were big enough animals
for you to eat and that accrues also for
the artists ours that it could for the
synapses of the Permian and any Vivien's
so know the end extinction the mass
extinction ends with the overturning of
the ecological pyramid and I'm saying
that humans cannot avoid that either why
because our economy the only thing that
produces food because we are an animal
that produces its own food that's gonna
disappear what's going to crash is the
global economy and when that crisis
money is no more because money is no
more you will not accept argentine pesos
anymore okay and when that happens you
don't produce you have no incentive to
permute for someone else that's the
theory that's what you got a challenge
okay and and if you want to challenge it
don't talk to me about humans start with
we'll start with the animals don't tell
me humans are not animals and therefore
I don't need to address that issue you
got to start with extinction 101 how did
the animals in the past I will see you
on Wednesday
and Wednesday that means Merry Christmas
for those of you who are religious again
we'll see you that bye-bye